what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 19 of
attack on time season 4 in which aaron
had his head blown off by gabby and
several important characters either died
or were turned into pure titans
today i'll be breaking down every single
thing that i felt needed explaining
including how everyone lost control of
the founding titan the real reason why
poco sacrificed himself and the history
behind every memory from the past
dimension
okay so the title of this episode was
two brothers which is referring not just
to the two jaeger brothers but also to
the two galliard brothers and the two
greich brothers in each of their
situations we saw that the older sibling
was trying to save the younger sibling
from something directly leading to the
major outcomes in this episode
to start things off it begins with the
attack titan limping towards zeke so
they can activate the founder only for
galliard to intervene yet again by
biting into his leg
i imagine at this point in the fight
aaron was just sick and tired of poker
annoying him so he repeatedly smashed
his hardened fist into the back of the
draw titan's neck by doing this he
wasn't just hurting the draw titan
himself but he was actually dealing
significant damage to poco's human body
inside as he went to hit him for the
sixth time there was a possibility that
galliard might have been killed but in
this moment macgas saved the warrior by
shooting the attack titan's brain
before he could take the second shot
against zeke the jaegers then appeared
and their main goal was to prevent the
general from firing again
as we can see pique was visibly angry at
them for interfering but the igress
didn't care since down on the ground the
beast titan was starting to regain
consciousness
one of the first things he noticed was
that aaron was having a hard time
against reiner and the armored titan was
trying to get poku involved in the fight
as well
in the past it's been shown that
physical touch between certain people
can cause memories to appear and by
reiner reaching out to galliard whilst
holding the founding titan it triggered
a memory that belonged to his brother
marcel up until now poco wasn't able to
see any of marcel's memories despite
having the same titan but in this new
scenario he was able to witness a quick
flashback
in this flashback marcel admitted to
rhino that he was never supposed to be a
warrior and it only happened because he
sabotaged his younger brother to protect
him this specific memory is super
important since porcu has always
resented rhino for being picked as the
armored titan as in his mind he was the
better candidate these feelings of
resentment weren't exactly helped by the
fact that marcel then died to save on
his life making porker believe that his
brother would still be alive if he was
chosen instead
what this memory proves though is that
he really was the better candidate all
along and his feelings of resentment
towards rhino were pointless since
marcel's love is the real reason why
poco never inherited the armor
the beast then starts to lift himself up
so he can summon his army of pure titans
which in this situation is his best
option to try and save aaron as he goes
to scream colts and falcon arrive at the
last second to interrupt him with the
older brother pleading his case for why
zeke shouldn't scream until falco is
outside of his range in this scene colt
mentions how the reason he wanted to
become a warrior was essentially to save
his family because if you don't know his
uncle was a prominent member of the
elding restorationist alongside
grishiega for that reason colt's desire
to become a warrior was to redeem the
grey's family name and to stop them
being turned into titans so naturally he
doesn't want that same fate for his
younger brother this scene in particular
has some amazing acting because he could
just hear the panic and desperation in
his voice but unfortunately although
zeke likes the grey's brothers he
doesn't like them enough to risk
sabotaging his dream that's why he
ultimately does make the choice to
scream and in the process he titanizes
everyone in chicago who drank the wine
this screenshot here demonstrates just
how wide the range of the screen really
was so even if zeke did allow falco some
time to escape it would have taken way
too long for gabby to take him far
enough
as the warrior candidate begins to
transform he sticks out his hand to say
goodbye to her while colt sacrifices
himself so he can stay with his brother
in their final moments
following this we get a ton of other
characters also transforming and by far
the most significant from our point of
view were nile and commander pixis the
commander in particular was downing a
bottle of alcohol on the battlefield
when it happened which is kind of an
indication that he'd already accepted he
was going to be titanized
back near the entrance of the wall
falco's rubber chicken titan made its
first appearance and because it was
created using zeke's spinal fluid it
meant the beast titan was able to
control him this same rule applies for
every pure titan the zeke has ever made
and to protect eren the first order he
gave falco was to go after reiner from
the warriors point of view he was now in
an impossible situation as he had to
fend off two titans simultaneously on
top of that his history with falco meant
that he hesitated to try and kill him
giving aaron a quick opening to break
three
the armor titan desperately tried to not
let him go that easily and by lunging
forward he was able to slow him down
however the drawback here was that
reiner had let go of his grip on falco a
second later while the falco titan was
trying to bite through ryan's neck
general magath did recover and was
finally able to fire at zeke again this
is cause all the jaegris on the wall had
been defeated with the exception of
flock who was taking cover so there
weren't any active soldiers to stop him
from shooting
if we flashed back to earlier in the
episode armin realized that dealing with
the card titan should be the scout's
main priority but by the time he and
mikasa arrived the beast had already
been shot
this is why armin assumed they were too
late but luckily down on the ground zeke
had somehow managed to survive again
what he done here was secretly crawl out
of his titan before magath was able to
fire and in this way his titan began to
disintegrate making everyone think he
was dead
this trick is similar to what pete did
in the previous episode and later on
zeke basically admits that he got the
idea from her
at this point in time aaron was the only
one to notice that his brother had done
this whereas rainer had absolutely no
idea because rhino believed that zeke
really was dead he thought the warriors
had completed their mission since in his
mind eric could no longer activate the
founding titan throughout the season so
far we've seen the armor titan has been
mentally prepared for death for a very
very long time so with his purpose
seemingly complete he was more than
happy to let falco eat him in this way
the young warrior candidate could return
back to his human form reiner himself
would be allowed to rest and gabby could
live a long life just like falco wanted
to happen
sadly though since this is attack on
titan that would have been way too easy
and instead poco shows up to offer
himself as a sacrifice
if you're wondering why galliard chose
to pass his draw tie into falco there
are two important reasons one which is
based in emotion and another which was a
more tactical decision
starting with the tactical choice this
relates to the injuries he received from
aaron the severity of the damage
resulted in him using up all of his
energy to get to his current state
meaning he was likely going to die no
matter what
in the end either his injuries would
have killed him or he'd be eaten by one
of the many pure titans roaming around
the district so rather than him dying
for no reason it made a lot more sense
to give himself to falco in the process
it also meant the armored titan would
still be able to fight if necessary
which is a lot better than ryder and
poker both dying and leaving pique as
the only active warrior in the battle
the second reason was that thanks to the
memory he saw earlier poco now knew for
certain that reiner was never meant to
be a warrior and all the suffering he
went through over the years is a direct
result of marcel's love for porco from
that perspective galliard likely felt
some kind of sympathy for rainer in the
same way his brother did cause like i
said his misery was the consequence of
marcel's choice
furthermore poco always considered
himself to be the better man in pretty
much every way and so he did what the
better man would do in this situation by
sacrificing his life for two comrades
who he perceives as weaker than himself
as a brief side note galliard saving
reiner makes this the sixth time by my
count that a holder of the draw titan
has saved him and if you give me a
second i'm going to list every single
one
the first time was of course when marcel
pushed him out of the way of yamir's
pure titan and the second time was when
yamir herself then saved him at utgard
castle the third time was when she saved
him again from this horde of titans and
the fourth time was when she willingly
agreed to go back to mali so that rhino
would receive a less severe punishment
for his failure
the fifth time was when galliard stopped
him from being blown apart by an
anti-titan cannon and now the sixth time
was him using himself as bait
anyhow after seeing poco's death reiner
absolutely loses it and punches the
attack titan in the mouth but aaron
hardens pretty much his entire body to
defend himself in the confusion he
breaks out of his titan and heads in
zeke's direction and this is when rhino
starts to realize that his mission isn't
actually done in this chaotic scene the
jaegerbros were just meters away from
making contact while jon and connie
showed up to hold off the armored titan
with thunderspears at the same time
armond and mikasa were dealing with the
car titan so all the main threats to
aaron from the start of the episode were
currently being distracted however after
the side we see a tearful gabby holding
colt's anti-tan rifle which remained
intact after colt was burned up by
falco's transformation this weapon
itself is specifically designed for
killing pure titans and not human beings
hence why a single shot from gabi was
enough to fully decapitate eren the
bullet pierced straight through his neck
instantly severing his spinal cord and
as we see his head spin towards zeke the
anime flashes back to this moment in
mali we already saw some of this scene
during the first half of the season when
aaron agreed to help with the
euthanization plan but this time around
we get an extended version
in this extended clip zeke tells him
that they're going to save everyone and
likely throws the baseball in his
direction only for his brother to then
completely miss it him dropping the ball
is the moment we didn't get to see in
part one and it signifies how just like
armin predicted aaron was never really
on board with zeke's plan the act of
throwing the baseball was these way of
showing that they were working towards
the same goal so by aaron dropping it it
made him question whether his brother
was being genuine
that's why later in the episode he
decides to test whether aaron is really
loyal to the euthanization plan because
those seeds of doubt were likely planted
in this scene in any case in the present
day time seems to almost stand still as
the marine soldiers are being eaten
across gigantic and we get this 2d shot
of rhino being thunderspeared which was
one of the nicest shots to come out of
this episode and there were quite a few
as the camera moves towards the front
gate the yeager brothers do finally make
contact as aaron's severed head falls
into zeke's hand and because he's
technically alive in this moment the
founding titan has now been activated
the anime then shows us this amazing
montage of memories flashing in front of
aaron's eyes and these memories include
things from the future the past and even
from alternate realities the first
vision we see is one of mikasa and this
is likely a reinterpretation of this
scene from the very first episode when
she had just woken him up from a dream
although the anime version and the manga
versions of the stream were different
the fact is that in both cases aaron saw
at least one memory from the future and
in this episode that's about to happen
again
up next there's a vision of rhino when
he was in the cadets and this was the
moment when he told aaron to keep moving
forward that catchphrase has become one
of eren's driving motivations ever since
so it's understandable why this memory
shows up after this we see one of
grisha's memories and this was of his
sister faye before she was killed by
malian officials grisha's angered his
sister's death was a large reason why he
chose to join the aldian restorationist
which is effectively what led all the
main characters to where they are now
following faye's appearance aaron then
sees a memory of frieda rice brushing
her hair and this one is from back in
season 3. back when he was tied up in
the rice chapel he saw this same memory
of frida in her bedroom and for a split
second it seemed like she could see him
back
the memories then transitioned to one of
reiner begging erin to kill him to
another from his childhood when armin
was playfully running away going past
armin's hair we then see the main
members of the rice family and this
memory belongs to grisha an interesting
detail is that there are clouds in the
background to represent the paradise
this family had before grisha showed up
and the background changes to red to
represent him killing them it then
switches to different fragments from
aaron's past including an image of
captain levi sasha and connie messing
around when they were in the cadets and
falco coming to eren for advice when he
was undercover in mali one of the
easiest memories to miss though was this
one that belonged to kruger and this
showed up right after falco's appearance
although the anime brushes passed it
super quickly this memory was a lot
clearer in the manga version and it's of
the moment when krueger's parents and
sister were about to be set on fire as
he explained in his backstory his dad
was one of the original alden
restorationists and because of that
connection his family were killed by
marley while he could only watch on from
his hiding place in the closet the next
scene then gives us a stylized version
of berto's colossal titan appearing in
front of bulmaria before moving on to
what can only be described as reiner and
levi and some other guys in a sauna this
is a reference to the alternate cover
for volume 31 of the manga although why
it appears in eren's memories is a bit
of a mystery if if we assume that
something like this did actually happen
then i'm just having a hard time
figuring out where it fits on the
timeline since levi had no reason to
relax with these guys when they were
cadets and after they graduated i just
don't i don't really see levi being in a
sauna with reiner specifically that
being said it's clearly here for a
reason so i mean maybe i've missed
something so if you have a good idea of
what this is about then do let me know
in the comments below
up next we get a brief vision of ramsay
who is a character that hasn't been
introduced in the anime yet but without
getting into spoilers this boy is
someone who ever met during his time in
mali many months ago the camera then
pans into ramsey's eyes to reveal a
haunting image of grishaiger screaming
while on his knees and based on what
he's wearing this is from the day he
massacred the ryze family
things then turn upside down to show a
very large bird flying towards fort
salter and again i'm not going to give
away spoilers here but this is the
memory from the future that i was
talking about fort salte is a very
important location in the history of
this series and the bird in question has
significance too as its origin can be
traced back to earlier in this episode
the key to grisha's basement then
appears on screen and transitions us to
the final set of memories the first of
which is of historia in this scene she
and aaron were having a conversation
about the future of the island and the
future of the world and this took place
before he went rogue in mali
that we literally get goth mikasa and
nerdy armin from attack on titan's
school class in this alternate reality
all of the main cast have drastically
different lives with levi being a
janitor pique being a news reporter
while armin mikasa and pretty much
everyone else is either a teacher or a
student at the school despite having the
manga volumes myself i personally never
care that much about schoolcast although
i know some people probably do
but the fact they actually put this in
the anime is basically a confirmation of
the attack on titan multiverse
in the original chapter when aaron saw
these memory shards i mean these
alternate versions of armin and mikasa
can be seen but i'm just surprised that
this gag has now become like 200 canon
by appearing in the anime as well
the last two memories to show up is
firstly one of the ocean which has a lot
of significance to aaron for obvious
reasons and then there's a different
vision of emir fritz who was the
original founding titan
this memory of the miera is pretty
significant as the camera zooms in to
show a bright flash of white light which
turns out to be the coordinate the
coordinate is where the paths connecting
all ldns converge into one and from this
place all subjects of emir are connected
through these parts the various memories
of every subject can be accessed and if
the founding titan wants to she can
manipulate the coordinate to alter the
bodies and minds of these aliens as well
anyhow after aaron's memory slideshow is
finished he manifests directly in front
of it in the past dimension while hobo
zeke is chained up behind him the reason
zeke's hair is longer than normal is
because time passes differently in this
reality and from his perspective it felt
like years until aaron arrived due to
the large amount of time he spent
trapped here alone he began to learn
various things about the founder
including the fact that the sand they're
standing on can be used by amir to
create anything
not only did she use it to rebuild his
body from scratch a couple episodes ago
but for the last two thousand years
she's been in here moulding titans from
scratch whenever someone needed their
power
now in order to explain how zeke got the
upper hand against aaron it's first
important to understand how the founding
titan actually works
to put it simply anything the founding
titan does or anything the founding
titan can do is because the emir is in
the past dimension making it happen so
essentially if you control your mirror
then you control the founder
historically speaking those who've
possessed the coordinate inside them
have always had royal blood so they had
no problem accessing the past dimension
and telling yamir what to do
in aaron's case though since he's a
regular eldian he needed the assistance
of zeke to get here and now that they're
both here ymir gives zeke priority due
to his royal blood
unlike the rice family he's arrived in
parts without actually having the
coordinate inside him and therefore he
hasn't been tated by the vow to announce
war which only affects royals who have
the founding titan for that reason he's
free to command yamir to do literally
anything he wants hence why he made her
create these chains his goal was to make
aaron believe that he'd been trapped by
the voucher announced war and in this
way he could test if aaron was really on
his side when it came down to it aaron
did take the bait and refused to use him
his powers for the euthanization plan
proving in zeke's mind that his
suspicion was correct and his brother
had been brainwashed by their father
remember ever since zeke found out that
he had a younger brother he assumed that
they'd both been brainwashed to become
alien restorationists from his
perspective it was sarva that saved him
from this mindset and now here in this
scene he wants to be the person to save
aaron the first time they met zeke even
promised that one day he would do this
so this encounter in the past dimension
is really just them coming full circle
by commanding emir zeke uses the
founder's power to restrict aaron in
these chains and his goal is to convince
his brother to join him in saving the
world of course his version of saving
the world means sterilizing every aldian
so it will be interesting to see how he
tries to convince aaron to do that in
the next episode
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 19 of attack on titan season 4
but one thing i quickly wanted to
mention was the reason falco disobeyed
the beast titan's order and went after
porco i didn't find the right moment to
talk about this earlier but essentially
in the beginning he follows these
instructions to go after reiner but at
the last second he abandoned that
objective to go after galliard an
explanation for this is that although he
was given orders sometimes titan
instincts can take priority and we've
seen that happen before with this titan
back in season 2. therefore falco
choosing to go after galileo does make
sense since pogo was completely out in
the open ready to be eaten whereas rhino
was still protected by this layer of
armor on top of that a few minutes had
passed and zeke gave the original
instruction so you know it's feasible
that after a while the will to follow a
certain task can be more easily
forgotten those are just my thoughts in
it but let me know your opinion in the
comments down below and don't forget to
hit that sub button if you want to see
more videos like this
until the next one peace out